Hey, Kilian. Hey, Hendrik.
Kennst du das eigentlich, wenn man an einer Bahn steht und eigentlich nur einen Podcast hören will
und plötzlich trifft man noch wie so bekannte Leute und dann fühlt man sich irgendwie obligated,
die Kopfhörer abzunehmen und sich mit denen zu unterhalten?
Das ist ganz schlimm. Ich habe das oft im Bus und ich gehe manchmal, ich weiß, das ist ein bisschen asie,
ich gehe manchmal aktiv Leuten aus dem Weg, wenn ich sehe, sie kommen gerade in die Bahn,
dann stelle ich mich vielleicht ein bisschen weiter weg oder schaue aufs Handy und tue,
so ob ich es einfach nicht mitbekomme, dass sie kommen. Das ist, ja, schwierig.
Witzig ist dann, wenn die andere Person eigentlich auch gerade Kopfhörer auf hat
und man dann weiß, okay, man könnte sich jetzt einfach bloß gepflegt ignorieren
und dann hört der andere seinen Podcast nicht mehr und man selbst hört keinen Podcast nicht mehr
und man ist witzig irgendwie gezwungen, sich zu unterhalten.
Aber das ist ja nicht wirklich gesellschaftlich akzeptabel, oder?
Warum haben wir uns dann vorhin überhaupt begrüßt?
Das ist scheiße.
Wir sind zufällig vorher in der Bahn überwirkend.
Jetzt kommt die Intro-Musik.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Wir brauchen auch
irgendwie einen Tusch
oder sowas.
Dabei ist sogar,
ich dachte gerade,
du hättest
hier irgendwo
in deiner Vielzahl
an Gitarren,
Keyboards
und sonstigen
musikalischem Equipment.
Ohne Scheiße,
hier stehen fünf Gitarren
um mich herum.
Fünf.
Ja, ich müsste die langsam
machen.
Ich hab immer nachgezählt.
Ich müsste die immer
abstauben,
ist nervt.
Ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ist da noch ein?
Ich täusche nicht.
Er meint.
Hier liegt noch Raum, ohne Rokulele.
Ja, wenigstens noch mit Stil.
Das ist jetzt unsere erste offizielle Folge.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar.
Ja, das ist jetzt unser Name, weil ein guter Podcast-Titel
muss ja akronomisierbar sein.
Was ist dann das Akronym für akronomisierbar?
Wir sind doch akronomisierbar, also.
Das heißt jetzt Folge
AKB 001?
AKB klingt wie AKB.
Nee, wir schmeißen den Namen nicht mal weg.
Wir sind AKB.
AKB. Zu lange für die
Namensgebung gebraucht.
AKA Ronny ist nie visierbar.
AKA.
Als Abkürzung.
Interessant.
Ne, wir wollten tatsächlich
heute und mal ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben mit
ein paar Themen, die wir uns
überlegt haben. Dafür, dass wir uns jetzt exakt
15 Minuten genommen haben, um diese Sendung
vorzubereiten und ist direkt
von der Arbeit gekommen und eigentlich komplett
im Arsch bin. Aber ja, lass uns ein bisschen reden.
Wie war dein Wochenende?
Wir haben doch schon Mittwoch.
Ja, ich habe...
Ich würde euch das Thema einleiten.
Ich war auf der Vostem.
Ah, erzähl mal davon.
Wirklich sage ich es nicht nur, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was die Vostem ist und was man da so machen kann.
Die Vostem ist irgendwie eine Konferenz, die schon seit 100 Jahren regelmäßig in Brüssel stattfindet.
Du warst in Brüssel?
Ich war in Brüssel.
Wunderschöne Altstadt.
Ich habe gehört, Brüssel ist das Crime Capital von Europa.
Das Hotel, in dem wir waren, war so knapp am Rand von Mohlbeek
und an den U-Bahn-Haltestellen stand überall Soldaten mit Maschinen.
Das war ein wenig bedrückend.
Aber wenn man sich mit dem Taxi bewegt, ist das ganz hübsch.
Und wenn man nur in der Altstadt unterwegs ist, merkt man davon auch nicht so viel.
Der Typ, mit dem ich unterwegs war, hat sich die ganze Zeit über das belgische Bier beschwert.
Das war fürchterlich.
Aber ja, ich bin auch wie spontan angefahren.
Letzte Woche habe ich mich mit dem Kumpel angequatscht, ob ich mitkommen möchte.
Und dann habe ich mir Freitag und Montag freigenommen.
Und dann sind wir da hingefahren.
acht stunden zug ordentlich ordentlich ist cool ist aber ich habe ein paar
leute wieder getroffen die von anderen konferenzen kann du so was geht es
generell so das ist eine open source konferenz für free and open source
software okay das ergibt und da da gibt es so tracks von mozilla dann gibt es
microkörner development tracks und gibt security tracks dann gibt es ich bin
gar nicht hinterher gekommen mit dem ganzen zeug ist es war ziemlich hoch
richtig so multitrack das ganze als konferenz also mehr dinge gleichzeitig
laufen ja es waren es war teilweise 20 talks gleichzeitig okay doch recht
groß dafür hat die uni einen komischen zustand also du läufst darum denkst du
so war und wie viele leute waren also da 8000 8000 also schon eine ordentlich
starke internationale sache der menschen ich war ich war den einen tag war ich
fast ausschließlich dem mozilla track drin habe ich dann ein bisschen was
erzählt bekommen zu Webrenderer
und den anderen Projekten, die sie machen, so von den Leuten,
die es teilweise selber bauen.
Das ist ganz nice. Aber
die
Akustik in den Sälen und die Mikrofone, mit denen
die gearbeitet haben, war ganz schrösterlich.
In einem Vortrag habe ich, haben wir
alle 10 Minuten, Viertelstunden
den Anfang fast nichts verstanden
und die Leute um mich drumherum, ich habe mich
nicht interessiert, ich habe einfach da gesessen und gehakt, weil es mich nicht interessiert hat.
Die Leute um mich drumherum, aber plötzlich so,
ich verstehe kein Wort.
Das ist witzig, die Leute haben abwechselnd Deutsch, Französisch,
Englisch. Achso, okay. Ich dachte thematisch,
jetzt ich verstehe kein Wort.
Und das heißt, nee, die Akustik war so
schlecht. Und der Typ,
der das Mikro anhatte, der hatte sich das an seinem T-Shirt
links angeklemmt, hat aber die ganze Zeit rechts zu seinem
Laptop rübergeguckt und hast immer nur dann
mal kurz verstanden, wenn er den Kopf gedreht hat.
Und dann habe ich dann einfach mal mit dem
drin reingerufen, excuse me, could you put the
microphone on the other side of your shirt?
Und der hat es noch weiter rausgeschoben.
Toll, klasse. Dann habe ich gesagt,
no, the other right.
Und dann konnte man ihn tatsächlich für den Rest des Vortrags verstehen.
Das hat auch eine Kunst, gut sprechen zu können.
Das ist wie geübt sein.
Allerdings, die Leute hat es nicht sonderlich interessiert.
Also wenn man vorher auf einem Chaos Communication Kongress war,
dann ist das halt nicht vergleichbar.
Der Kongress ist aber auch kein Master.
Also der Kongress ist unglaublich gut organisiert,
obwohl er ja, also die Leute stecken da richtig, richtig viel Arbeit rein.
Und ich bin immer wieder begeistert, wie toll jeder Kongress ist.
ja vor allem auch die freiwilligen organisation funktioniert ziemlich gut
alles super aber trotzdem zeit man beim kongress halt 150 euro und bei der
foster nichts ja aber es gibt auch kongress andere also andere
veranstaltungen wo du bedeuten mehr zahlen bedeuten schlecht organisiert als
der kassel im nächsten kurs also allein die freiwilligen organisationen hätten
sind bisschen besser hinkriegen können da hat sich auch jemand beschwert die
hätten wohl genug ich schätze die hätten genug freiwillige helfer zusammen
gekriegt aber sie haben es auch wenig anständig möchte jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie jemandem was unterstellen das hat an einigen stellen hat es immer mal
habe ich den Eindruck. Okay, das ist ja schade, aber wenn bei einer Sache von der Größe ist das
manchmal sogar auch nicht umgänglich. Naja, da sind so ein paar Typen rumgelaufen, die mir auch
bekannt vorkamen. Also einen habe ich vom Kongress wiedererkannt, eine Gruppe aus London, mit dem bin
ich dann abends auch mal rumgezogen. Ein paar Leute aus Leipzig, die mit der ganzen Firma angereist
waren oder mit der Hälfte der Firma angereist waren. Das waren die Leute von Spreadshirt.
Schön ein Gruß übrigens. Ich habe heute was bei Spreadshirt bestellt. Ja, ich kenne jetzt wie fit von
den Entwicklern.
Die sitzen in Leipzig, ganz nice. Und dann saß ich in
eurem Vortrag über WireGuard
und
da sitzt auch so ein großer, glatzköpfiger Typ
nicht mehr. Ich denke mal, den Typen kenne ich
irgendwoher, der kommt mir bekannt vor und quatscht den an,
auf Englisch dann. Sag mal, kennen wir uns
irgendwoher? Dein Gesicht
kommt mir bekannt vor. Kennen wir uns irgendwie?
Bist du vielleicht ein Berliner CCC? Kennen wir uns vom
Kongress oder sowas? Und der bloß so,
nee, du, ich war noch nie beim
Kongress und ich bin noch nicht mehr im CCC.
Woher kenne ich dich denn?
keine Ahnung, ich halte manchmal
Vorträge, ja, kann sein, vielleicht
habe ich dich in irgendeinem YouTube-Video gesehen, wie heißt
du? Ja, Greg.
Und der ist,
kam raus, das war Greg
Crohart-Hartman,
einer der Haupt-Linux-Körner
der Main-Tainer.
Mit dem noch eine gequatscht. Aber so, gerade wenn du
jemanden fragst, der an solchen Projekten dranhängt,
dann sollte der doch wissen, woher man ihn vielleicht kennen
könnte. Ja, der hätte theoretisch
sagen können, ja, du kennst mich bestimmt,
ich bin einer der Haupt-Linux-Colonel-Maintainer.
Aber na gut.
Vielleicht kriegt man da nicht mehr so viel Fame.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Der hat ja eine witzige Geschichte rausgehauen,
dass er kurzzeitig mal gefragt wurde,
ob er nicht in Dresden den Betriebssystem-Lehrstuhl übernehmen möchte.
Hat dann aber abgelehnt,
weil er irgendwie mit Micro-Colonel
nicht so viel anfangen kann.
Schade.
Das war sehr witzig.
Ja, ansonsten gab es irgendwie
einen Haufen Fressboden.
Sehr, sehr, sehr schlimme Hamburger von Leuten aus so einem ollen, schäbigen Wagen raus,
die sonst Hot Dogs machen.
Die haben Burger genauso gemacht wie Hot Dogs.
Die haben so ein Brot genommen, aufgeschnitten, aber nicht ganz.
Das hat noch an einer Stelle noch zusammengehackt.
Die haben halt diesen Einablauf gelernt.
Dann haben sie aus dem Ofen so eine Art Patty da reingelegt.
Dann haben sie ein bisschen Ketchup drauf gemacht und klein geschnittene Zwiebeln drüber,
so reingedrückt quasi.
Das für 4 Euro.
Gut, ordentlich.
Ja, wenn es nicht die kürzeste Schlange gewesen wäre,
hätte ich es nicht gegessen.
Was ich überhaupt nicht geschafft habe,
ranzukommen, war der Kaffeestand von Github.
Die haben nämlich die ersten 500 Kaffee oder sowas
oder den ersten Vormittag haben sie einen Kaffee verschenkt
und da war eine riesen Schlange dran
und da hast du ein schönes Pappbecher mit Github drauf.
Oh, die sind auch bei ihm.
Genau.
Das ist cool.
Das war die Vorstärmen.
Das waren 8 Stunden Zugfahrt hin und her.
Wie lang war die ganze Sache?
das war Samstag
früh bis Sonntagabend
wir sind aber Freitag
Vormittag schon los und Montag
Vormittag erst wieder zurück
das Schöne ist in der Deutschen Bahn in den ICE
es gibt jetzt WLAN
erstens gibt es das ja schon seit
Ewigkeiten, aber du kommst halt nicht wirklich
raus ins Internet, sondern nur auf diese
ICE interne Webseite, die dir die aktuelle
Geschwindigkeit anzeigt
du hattest so eine Vorschaltseite
da musstest du einmal ok klicken
aber dann hattest du WLAN
Es hat gereicht, dass ich so ein bisschen...
Das funktioniert auch in der Pampa.
Es ging einigermaßen. Es hat gereicht, dass ich ein paar YouTube-Videos gucken konnte.
Ich habe es noch nie funktionieren gesehen. Noch kein einziges Mal.
War das in Ordnung?
Ich übertreibe nicht, kein einziges Mal hat das bei mir bisher geklappt.
Vielleicht haben sie es gerade erst hingekriegt, aber das funktioniert jetzt einigermaßen.
Beeindruckend. Die Deutsche Bahn macht technische Fortschritte.
Das war was weiß ich.
Hat das mit der Open Data irgendwie zu tun?
Kann man auch Open Internet?
Open Data in der Straschbahn?
Die treiben doch ihre Kampagne da voran.
Und die haben es vor kurzem, das heißt vor kurzem,
wenn sie Gruppen ein Jahr oder ein bisschen mehr her,
ist die Deutsche Bahn so ein bisschen auf so einen Open Data Trip gekommen
und hat angefangen, hauptsächlich Daten zu veröffentlichen.
Es hat angefangen mit relativ unspannten, in Anführungsstrichen, Dingen,
würde ich mal behaupten.
Gerade was so den Status von Aufzügen in Bahnhöfen angeht,
ob die kaputt sind oder nicht.
Ganz einfach.
Aber sie haben halt irgendwo angefangen.
Und das Problem bei der Bahn ist,
das haben sie auch in diesem Open Data Blog, den sie führen,
recht oft beschrieben,
ist, dass sie eine unglaubliche Vielfalt an Daten haben.
Und diese Daten über eine unglaubliche Vielzahl von Subunternehmen verteilt sind.
Und da ranzukommen ist halt nicht nur ein technischer Aufwand,
sondern ein unglaublicher genereller Aufwand, was so alles angeht.
Du musst mit den Leuten reden, du musst diese Daten irgendwie da rauskriegen,
du musst die irgendwie zugänglich machen, du musst irgendwie das aufbereiten,
du musst die Leute erstmal davon überzeugen, dass das eine tolle Sache ist.
Aber die haben intern da eben Fortschritte.
Und mittlerweile kriegst du sogar, ich glaube, die Timetable-Informationen sind schon da.
Aktuelle Fahrtdaten noch nicht, soweit ich weiß.
Das ist immer so dieser heilige Gral.
Es gibt so eine Webseite.
Es gibt direkt eine DB Open Data Seite.
Die packen auf jeden Fall mal die Show-Lots mit rein.
Ich kenne die URA jetzt auch nicht aus dem Kopf.
Ich habe da mal eine Zeit lang auf dem Blog mitgelesen im RSS-Feed.
Entweder passiert da schon eine Weile nichts mehr
oder ich habe das mal aus Versehen irgendwo deabonniert.
Aber es war auch mal ganz spannend, was die so besprechen.
Und die gehen das halt witzig an.
Die Deutsche Bahn ist ein riesiges Unternehmen.
Aber die gehen das so an von wegen,
ja, wir wissen auch nicht so wirklich, wie wir das jetzt veröffentlichen.
Wir geben euch hier mal auf dem Test-Server eine Schnittstelle bereit.
Macht damit mal was.
Wenn es kaputt geht, dann ist das halt blöd.
Ich kann mich richtig reinversetzen in die Leute,
die dafür verantwortlich sind. Das sind so
ein, zwei Hacker wie du und ich. Die haben sich aber
angestellt, ihr macht jetzt hier mal was. Ihr kriegt jetzt
Juckzuck das und das Bild mal raus, was geht.
Und dann fangen sie halt so langsam an,
sich in deren Archäologie reinzugraben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Die Seite heißt
übrigens data.deutschebahn.com
Die haben so ein schönes... Ja genau, das ist die Seite.
Instacode.es
Also das E ist Teil der TLD schon.
Die haben so eine wunderschöne, schräg
abfotografierte Stelle Sourcecode da
als Bild. Ist aber schick.
Also die Seite ist schon nett. Ist halt in WordPress
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Also ich erinnere mich an
ein Mobile Camp vor zwei
Jahren oder so. Das ist diese
in der Fakultäne Informatik der TU Dresden
stattfindendes Bar Camp, was glaube ich
so zwei Tage im Juli jedes Jahr sind.
Müsste bald wieder sein. Ist noch Februar.
Oder im Juni. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau wann es ist.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache, weil die letzten Jahre
immer da. Hat auch echt Spaß gemacht. Geht hauptsächlich
um mobile Entwicklungen und Kram. Und da
und ein Typ oft vorbei, ein bisschen
so in Steampunk-Attire.
David Wasser heißt der. Cooler Typ, sehr sympathisch.
Arbeitet.
Ich weiß nicht, bei irgendeiner Firma spielt keine große Rolle.
Jetzt macht
aber auf jeden Fall für die Deutsche Bahn auch Dinge.
Und ein Kumpel und ich hatten
da eben eine Idee, eine App
zu schreiben. Die haben wir angefangen.
Den Namen haben wir keinen großen Gedanken
gemacht, gab es noch nicht. Die Idee war
so eine Art Spiel, was du in der
Bahn spielen kannst, auf dem Handy.
Du kannst wetten darauf, ohne Echtgeld, weil
wollten nicht in den rechtlichen Aspekt reinraten, aber du kannst
mit Punkten oder mit Spielgeld halt wetten,
wie viel Verspätung dein aktueller Zug
haben wird, wenn er ankommt.
Und wer halt am nächsten ist, kriegt halt die
meisten Punkte und kannst halt für Magic
Internet Points dir generell immer...
Hätte man ein paar Bonusmeilen für verschenken.
Das Problem ist, wir hatten
keine Ahnung, wo die Daten bei mir herbekommen und hatten
diese Idee gerade da gehabt und haben halt diesen
David Weiser mit angequatscht, ein bisschen, hey,
du arbeitest doch mit DB zusammen, wie schaut's denn
aus, kriegt man da irgendwo Daten? Und er hat einfach nur uns ausgelacht.
Es klingt jetzt gemein, aber er hat halt immerhin gesagt,
nee, könnt ihr vergessen, da gibt es überhaupt nichts.
Und kurze Zeit später ging eben dieses DB Open Data los.
Und da habe ich mich tierisch gefreut.
Aber sie haben halt nie das gehabt.
Also bis jetzt glaube ich zumindest nicht, was wir brauchten.
Die Idee ist auch ein bisschen eingeschlafen.
Ich fände es immer noch witzig, das anzugehen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Du steigst in die Bahn mit Leuten, dann machst du deinen Pott auf.
Oder vielleicht auch sogar, da siehst du auch noch,
wer anderes mit dem Zug sitzt und das spielt.
Und dann, die Bahn könnte damit tatsächlich sogar werben.
Dass sie sagen, guck mal hier, du achtest jetzt mehr darauf,
wenn du das häufiger spielst, wie sehr wir Verspätung haben.
Du merkst, wir haben gar nicht so viel Verspätung, wie Leute immer sagen.
Oder was könnten sie damit machen?
Ja, aber das wäre halt, wenn die PR-Abteilung die Verspätung verstecken könnte.
Also meine Erfahrung ist, dass die Bahn zumindest, mit der ich regelmäßig fahre,
also ich fahre jetzt nicht häufig Bahn, aber so alle zwei Monate ungefähr mal nach Hause vielleicht,
nach Ingolstadt, nach Hause Hause zu meinen Eltern.
Und die Bahn hat jedes Mal Verspätung, jedes Mal.
Witzigster Fall war einmal, da hatte sie das Ticket zwei Tage zuvor gekauft,
war in der DB Navigator App bereits angekündigt, dass die Bahn Verspätung haben wird.
Zwei Tage danach.
Und am Bahnsteig habe ich dann auf die Bahn gewartet.
Ich muss immer einmal umsteigen.
Am Bahnsteig hieß es dann, ja, die Bahn hat unerwartet eine Stunde Verspätung
wegen Menschen auf den Streck, wegen Tieren auf den Gleisen.
Unerwartet.
So das, was zwei Tage zuvor schon angekündigt war, auf der Seite.
Vielleicht hat er da auch einen Schäfer schon angekündigt,
dass er seine Erde da drüber treiben würde.
Das ist beschuldig.
Das musst du ja irgendwie angeben.
Aber was so Verspätungen und Werbeungen
gibt, die hatten mal ganz kurzzeitig
so einen Werbespot,
wo Leute am Gleis stehen,
müssen wir mal auf YouTube raussuchen,
da stehen Leute am Gleis
und dann kommt die Leute und sagt, der ICE
so und so von Oberpfaffenhofen nach
Ingolstadt hat heute
10 Minuten Verspätung und dann fangen die Leute
an sich zu empören. 10 Minuten!
10 Minuten!
und fangen dann an, sich so kollektiv aufzuregen
und fangen dann an zu tratschen und dann ziehen sie los
und dann haben sie plötzlich Plakate in der Hand
und dann stehen sie vor der Bahnzentrale
und dann sagen sie, 10 Minuten
Verspätung, können wir nicht akzeptieren
und die Quintessenz von der Geschichte war dann irgendwie
ja, mit den Besten
ist man immer am strengsten oder auch
und sowas, weil die Bahn ja so toll
ist. Der Spot lief glaube ich
drei Tage dann auch standen
vor der Bahnzentrale und da haben sie
mit einer Plakataktion gegen
10 Minuten Verspätung
beschwert.
Kleiner Lippig, Paffenhofen ist maximal
so 10 Minuten von England-Beschwerden.
Wahnsinn.
Da brauchst du schon doppelt so lange.
Witziges Detail,
Fun-Fact sozusagen,
die japanischen Bahnunternehmen
sind sehr, sehr effizient
und wenn die da halt wenige,
also ich glaube ab einer Minute Verspätung
ist das Stoff für nationale Nachrichten bei denen.
Krass. Und wir haben halt
die Deutsche Bahn und leben damit.
Das ist echt traurig.
Ich will nicht rumhaken auf der Bahn.
Also in Brüssel waren die Busse relativ
voll teilweise, gerade wenn du von der Konferenz
weggefahren bist, weil alle gleichzeitig da aufgebrochen sind.
Die Stadtbusse meinst du? Die Stadtbusse.
Ich bin gerade aus unserem
Pad geschmissen worden, du auch? Ja.
Okay.
Hauptsache, wir können das weiterlesen.
Zumindest war es dann relativ voll und dann war halt
der Bus voller Nerds und die haben alle
Deutsch oder Englisch gesprochen untereinander.
Da war irgendwie eine halbe Mozilla-Crew mit drin.
und die standen halt alle so, dass wir nicht mal mehr umfallen könnten,
wenn der Bus gebremst hätte.
Wir sind glücklicherweise auch alle Richtung Altstadt gefahren
und dort wieder ausgestiegen.
Die reine Anzahl an nerdigen Kompressionswitzen, die da sind.
Es ist immer geil, wenn man gerade Leute in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln sieht,
von denen man genau weiß, wo die herkommen oder wo die hingehen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das war zum Carous Communication Congress vor zwei Jahren,
also zum 32 C3, bin ich mit dem ICE von München nach Hamburg gefahren
und irgendwann haben Leute angefangen,
im Zug LAN-Kabel zu verlegen.
Und das fand ich aber großartig.
Ah ja, wir haben das selbe Ziel. Wunderschön.
Ja, ich hatte mir irgendwie so eine Checkliste
für Sachen für den Kongress, die man unbedingt dabei haben muss,
aufgeschrieben letztes Mal, weil ich
vorletztes Jahr dran gedacht habe
und dieses Jahr habe ich es total vergessen gehabt.
Also man braucht definitiv Stromverteiler,
extra Akkus, Decktelefon,
Internetkabel,
ein Switch,
bunten LED-Scheiß,
Gaffer, alles mögliche.
Und ich hatte extra so ein bisschen Netzwerkequipment
und einen extra Akku auf die Foster mitgenommen.
Ich war echt froh, dass ich den zweiten Akku für meinen Laptop dabei hatte.
Den Laptop?
Weil es nirgendwo Strom gab.
Das ist kacke.
Absolut kacke.
Also die Uni, es gab ein, zwei schöne Hörsäle,
aber größtenteils sah das alles so nach 1960, 70 aus.
Dann ist es ganz schlimm und alt und Räume ohne Fenster.
sieht alles ein bisschen nach
neue Mensa.
Okay, ich meine, gerade wenn du
Uni-Räume nutzt, dann hast du das wahrscheinlich generell.
Naja,
also ich würde mir vorstellen, wenn sowas bei uns wäre.
Haben wir so moderne
Hörsaalzentrum? Wir haben das
Hörsaalzentrum, was ein relativ moderne,
wo du könntest bestimmt echt einen coolen Kongress im Hörsaalzentrum
abhalten, so komplett. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Da hast du Seminarräume
an der Seite, die große Fenster haben.
Und du hast ja größere Hörsaalzentrum,
mehrere sogar. Das würde echt gut klappen.
müssen wir die Forstdämmen nach Dresden holen.
Würde wahrscheinlich aus Brandschutzgründen maximal 100 Leute
gleichzeitig ins Gebäude lassen.
Aber klingt ja eine coole Sache.
Ist das jedes Jahr die Forstdämmen?
Ja, ist komplett kostenlos.
Dafür darfst du dich halt über nichts beschweren.
Und wie wird das organisiert?
Durch Spenden von Firmen
und Organisationen generell?
Ich glaube, so viel machen die gar nicht.
Die machen bestimmt einiges,
aber im Endeffekt belegen die bloß
die Hörsäle mit Zeugs,
halten da Vorträge mit dem ganz normalen Uni-Equipment.
Das ist doch immer dort, in Brüssel.
Ja, in der ULB, in der Universität
Liberté in Brüssel.
Wunderschön.
Wir laufen so durch die Stadt und werden von der Seite
angequatscht von einer Frau, die uns
auf Französisch offenbar nach irgendeiner Straße
fragt. Und ich hatte mich schon lange auf
sowas vorbereitet,
weil ich absolut
kein Französisch spreche.
Ich war kurz davor zu sagen, je ne pas pas français.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich, ich spreche kein Französisch.
Ich spreche kein Französisch. Ich wollte das aber anpassen,
weil wir waren ja zu zweit.
Achso, wir sprechen kein Französisch.
Und deswegen habe ich dann gesagt,
und die Frau hat sich kaputt gelacht
und ist weitergegangen, weil ich ihr nämlich gerade
unterschätzt, dass sie kein Französisch spricht.
Sie sprechen kein Französisch.
Dankeschön.
Großartig.
Also ich glaube, korrekt wäre gewesen,
schreibt mir mal auf Twitter,
was ich eigentlich hätte sagen sollen,
aber...
Wir sprechen kein Französisch.
Aber gut, okay.
Es hat meine Aussage eigentlich
nur unterbrochen.
Das ist einfach geil.
Du musst einfach Leute so anmachen.
Das kannst du machen,
das kannst du, glaube ich, machen,
wenn du in der Innenstadt unterwegs bist und dir immer Tickets
oder irgendwie so WWF oder irgendwelche Sachen
verkaufen möchtest.
Oder unter einer Unterschriftenaktion
und du möchtest da einfach dran vorbei.
Ich habe da manchmal schon gesagt, dass ich nur Englisch spreche,
aber die Leute, die sowas machen, sprechen natürlich
Fließendenglisch, weil du einfach sagst, du sprichst kein
Deutsch. Also du sagst einfach,
du sprichst kein Deutsch.
Ich glaube, wenn ich derjenige
werde, die Person anspringt, ich würde einfach nicht verstehen,
was du von mir willst in dem Moment.
Hä? Hä? Was?
Nee, das ist eine interessante Taktik.
Ja, das war so mein
Fuck-Up an dem Wochenende, aber es war sehr
witzig. Das ist doch eine nette
kleine Sache.
Ja, wenn wir schon bei
bei Fuckups sind. Wir haben generell
Fuckups mal ins Themenpad
mit aufgenommen. Mein privater
Fuckup der Woche des Monats
ist vorgestern gewesen.
Da habe ich nämlich fröhlich mal ein iPhone
zurücksetzen wollen. Das iPhone
meiner Freundin hat generell schon immer mal wieder
so ein paar Spinnereien gemacht und das
passiert unter iOS nur wieder mal, dass das System
irgendwann, keine Ahnung, woran das liegt,
BitRot, korrupte Dateien,
keine Ahnung. Aber man kann
hin und wieder mal sein Gerät zurücksetzen. Das finde ich gar nicht schlimm.
Das passiert ja nicht oft, alle paar Jahre.
wie auch immer, Updates drüber spielen,
die Geräte nicht nur starten, ich wundere mich eh, dass die so
relativ gut laufen
und habe halt vor Ewigkeiten
schon mal, weil sie nur die 5 GB
Free iCloud
Backup, iCloud Space nutzt
und da keine Backups mit reinpassen,
ihr gesagt, dass sie das über
iTunes machen kann, hat sie dann auch gemacht, Backups über iTunes
und ich habe noch
dazu gefügt, dass iTunes
generell nicht alle Daten in das Backup
schiebt, aber du iTunes sagen kann,
dass er das Backup verschlüsseln soll, dann speichert er tatsächlich
auch WiFi-Passwörter und HealthKit-Daten,
also deine Bewegungsdaten und so weiter.
Eigentlich will man ja, dass ein Backup möglichst komplett ist, logischerweise.
Also haben wir das Backup auch verschlüsselt.
Und dafür hat man ein Passwort eingesetzt,
was ich interessanterweise vergessen habe.
Aber darauf kommen wir ja gleich noch.
Jedenfalls haben wir fröhlich dann Backups gemacht
und regelmäßig auch jedes Mal
das Gerät als iTunes angeschlossen,
so derart und Weise, wie man Backups gemacht hat,
bevor es die iCloud gab bei Apple.
Und jedenfalls
haben wir dann das Gerät zurücksetzen wollen
und haben halt ein Backup gemacht, ein sehr aktuelles.
Ich sehe, dass dieses Backup existiert.
Das war das einzige Backup, was aktuell in iTunes drin war zu dem Zeitpunkt.
War drei Minuten alt und haben das Gerät zurückgesetzt.
Also auf Werkzeichenstelle zurückgesetzt, iOS neu installiert da drauf über iTunes
und dann auch versucht das Backup wiederherzustellen.
Und dann fragt iTunes plötzlich nach einem Passwort.
Ja, das Gerätepasswort, sicherlich der PIN-Code.
Nein, falsches Passwort.
Dann natürlich das Account-Passwort vom iCloud-Account,
weil das ist ja auch das, was ich generell nutze, um alles bei Apple zu authentifizieren.
Nein, falsches Passwort.
fuck. Und jetzt?
Meine Freundin hat sich
daran erinnert, dass ich vor Ewigkeit mal
ein Passwort entweder ausgedacht habe,
sie oder ich, oder
generiert wird ein Passwortmanager. Ich habe schon keinen
Passwortmanager gefunden, sie nicht in ihrem,
ich nicht in meinem. Wir haben
diesen Zettel nicht gefunden, auf dem es vielleicht mal gestanden haben
könnte. Das Passwort war weg. Keine Ahnung,
was das Passwort war. Und das ist jetzt natürlich
ziemlich scheiße, weil ich finde das unglaublich
kacke von iTunes, dass dieses Backup
gemacht wurde. Das ist drei Minuten
alt gewesen, dieses Backup. Ich habe fröhlich die Daten
da reinschieben können, aber ich kriege sie nicht mehr raus.
Und die werden von iTunes eben halt komplett verschlüsselt
auf die Platte gelegt. Ich habe dieses Backup sichern können.
Ich habe eine Sicherheitskopie auf meinem Rechner.
Nur falls iTunes der Meinung ist, das jetzt irgendwie
irgendwann mal zu löschen.
Und weiß halt nicht, wie ich an diese Daten jetzt wieder rankomme.
Bruteforce. Ich habe über Nacht
unsere beiden Rechner versucht, das Ding zu bruteforcen.
Wir haben uns sehr, sehr viele Gedanken darüber gemacht,
was das Passwort sein könnte. Wie hast du das versucht zu bruteforcen?
Gibt es da wie ein Tool? Da gibt es diverse Tools für.
Die sind alle ein bisschen creepy,
aber da gibt es Optionen und ich
wollte mich nicht damit auseinandersetzen,
wie die Verschlüsselung aussieht.
Apple nutzt da wohl AES,
um das Passwort zu sichern.
Und dazu noch, ich bin jetzt kein Experte,
was auch immer PBK, BF2 ist.
Ich glaube, irgendeinen Hashing-Algorithmus,
den du davor noch schieben kannst.
Der möglichst langsam ist.
Auf jeden Fall kannst du das bruteforcen.
Und da gibt es auch Tools, die laufen auf der GPU.
Das war ganz nett.
Und die kriegen tatsächlich, ich glaube,
15.000 Passwortversuche pro Sekunde hin.
Aber du brauchst halt trotzdem,
wir haben mit dem ersten Dictionary-Tag versucht
und uns stundenlang Gedanken gemacht,
wenn wir uns das Passwort selber ausgedacht haben.
Es ist ja nur ein lokales Passwort.
Es wird ja nirgendwo hingeschrieben, das Backup.
Deshalb muss es ja nicht das sicherste Passwort sein.
Haben uns halt stundenlang Gedanken gemacht.
Alles mögliche, was uns eingefallen ist,
in verschiedenen Kombinationen in eine Textratei gepackt,
in dieses Programm mit reingefüttert
und eine Dictionary-Tag machen lassen.
130.000 Passwörter hat er daraus generiert.
Modifikation war nicht das Richtige dabei.
Mir geht das immer so,
wenn ich mich irgendwo einloggen will
und das Passwort vergessen habe,
dann bin ich einfach so faul
und lass mir so eine E-Mail zuschicken
und er erzeugt mir ein neues Passwort.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich dann überlege,
was könnte ich denn jetzt hier so als Passwort vergeben,
fällt mir mein altes Passwort immer wieder ein.
Und dann gebe ich das meistens einfach nochmal ein.
Und wenn die dann creepy sind,
sagen die mir,
ihr neues Passwort doch mit ihrem alten Passwort nicht wahr.
Das ist natürlich blöd dann.
Das ist dann immer ein schlechtes Zeichen.
Ja, aber das hat halt nicht gebracht.
Wir haben beide Rechner, wie gesagt,
versucht, das über Nachtblut forsten zu lassen.
Aber da wir keine Ahnung hatten,
wie lang das Passwort ist
und welche Komplexität und welche Zeichen beinhaltet,
Kannst du da halt vergessen, da ranzukommen.
Ich meine, das Programm hat netterweise noch angezeigt,
dass es noch 100 Jahre braucht, um alles durchzuprobieren.
Das war sehr ermutigend natürlich.
Aber wir haben nichts gefunden.
Was ich ein bisschen gemeint finde,
ist, wenn du dasselbe Problem auf einem Mac hast.
Also sie hat einen Windows-Rechner, ich habe einen Mac.
Auf einem Mac schiebt iTunes dieses Passwort in deine Keychain.
Und da kannst du es natürlich auch einfach wieder auslesen.
Da kannst du dir anzeigen lassen, in der Keychain, was da drinsteckt,
wenn du dein Systempasswort eingibst.
Wunderbar. Auf dem Windows-Rechner ist das nicht der Fall.
Es gibt sogar auf dem Windows-Rechner, habe ich gelernt, eine Art Keychain,
heißt Credential Manager.
Da landen von IE gespeicherte Passwörter zum Beispiel drin.
Da liegt es natürlich nicht drin.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgesucht und habe eine SQLite DB gefunden,
die in einem iTunes-Data-Verzeichnis liegt.
Die heißt Keychain.db.
Ist eine SQLite-Datenbank, kann ich reinschauen.
Liegen haufenweise verschlüsselte Daten oder Binary Blobs drin,
kann ich persönlich nicht direkt mit anfangen.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgegoogelt.
Niemand hat davon auch irgendwas im Internet geschrieben,
dass das überhaupt existiert.
Ich habe mal auf AskDifferent,
diese Stack Exchange für Apple mal gefragt
und habe da
eine Frage gestellt. Leute haben ein bisschen
Anführungsvorschlägen
vorgeschlagen, aber nichts, was damit direkt zusammenhängt.
Also ich bin kurz davor, die Hoffnung
aufzugeben, aber mir fällt einfach nichts mehr ein, wie ich
wieder an das Passwort kommen könnte. Oh mein Gott, wir brauchen
Hilfe. Helft, Kian.
Es ist halt so unglaublich
gemein, dass iTunes, vor allem das
Beschissene ist, ich kann iTunes dieses
Encryption-Passwort nicht ändern. Ich kann es nicht deaktivieren
und nicht ändern, ohne das alte Passwort einzugeben.
Ich kann jetzt nicht mal neue Backups machen, lokale, ohne das alte Passwort zu haben.
Apples offizielle Hilfe an dieser Stelle ist, deinstalliere iTunes, installiere iTunes neu
und setze dann dein iOS-Gerät komplett auf Werkseinstellung zurück, ohne ein Backup,
denn dann kannst du dein neues Encryption-Passwort vergeben.
Was ist das denn für eine beschissene Hilfe?
Das ist der beschissenstmögliche Vorschlag.
Ich bin echt aufgeschmissen an der Stelle.
Ich weiß nicht weiter.
Es sind halt echt viele Daten, gerade was gemeinene Fotos angeht, weg.
Und das tut mir unglaublich leid, weil ich sehe da auch ein bisschen meine Schuld drin.
Aber das ist doch kacke, es muss doch irgendeine Lösung dafür geben.
Das ist auf jeden Fall mein persönlicher Fuck-up der Woche,
beziehungsweise des Monats wahrscheinlich.
Und ich komme auf keinen Grund Zweig und hätte gerne,
dass Apple sich bei mir meldet und einfach sagt,
hier, wir geben dir irgendwelche iTunes,
du veröffentlichst bitte nichts darüber,
aber wenn du uns das Backup schickst,
dann nutzen wir die internen iTunes-Equipition-Keys
und entschlüsseln dir iTunes-Sicherungskopie von deinem Passwort,
mit dem das ja seit Monaten dein Backup verschlüsselt,
ohne dass du es neu eingegeben hast,
und geben dir die Daten wieder.
Ich habe dieses Equipment-Passwort immer eingegeben
vor ein paar Monaten, aber nie wieder.
Und iTunes hat halt Backups gemacht früher.
Das musste es ja irgendwo persistiert haben.
Hast du auch die Passwörter erzeugt mit dem Passwortmanager?
Ich weiß es halt nicht mehr.
Wenn ich es hätte, dann hätte ich es hoffentlich gespeichert.
Und wenn ich so doof hätte,
hätte ich es einfach weggeschmissen danach.
Wir sind halt auch einmal umgezogen.
Und deshalb ging es ja Zettel wahrscheinlich auch weg,
auf den ich es geschrieben habe, wenn ich es getan habe.
Ich erinnere mich halt auch an nichts mehr davon.
Ich habe tatsächlich mit der Idee gespielt,
mich hypnotisieren zu lassen.
diese Erinnerungen mehr anzukommen.
Kennst du Leute, die Leute hypnotisieren?
Nee, ich kenne auch niemanden.
Ich würde sogar mal versucht werden,
zu hypnotisieren, weil ich da einfach null so glaube.
Ich habe mal bei so einer Hypnoseschau mitgemacht.
Die Versprechung war ja, dass eine Stunde Hypnose
so viel wert ist wie drei Stunden Tiefschlaf.
So von der Entspannung her.
Interessant.
Ich bin aber leider nicht auf die Bühne geholt worden.
Aber da hat er vorher so eine Auswahl gemacht.
Mit den Leuten machen wir hier das und das.
Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, so und so,
um zu testen, wer am besten darauf reagiert.
Und hat da so ein paar Leute ausgewählt.
und die hat er dann auf der Bühne
schön verarscht und die Sachen machen lassen.
Sehr krass.
Warst du Teil dieser Person oder Zuschauer?
Nee, ich bin, wie gesagt, nicht ausgewählt worden.
Ich war kein Zuschauer, aber ich wollte
mich auf die Bühne auswählen lassen.
Das war ein bisschen weird. Er hatte dann
mit einem Typen
eingeredet, dass er schwanger ist
und dass die Wehen einsetzen.
Das war aber schlecht,
weil er hat sich hinterher tatsächlich noch über Schmerzen
beschweren. Ah, scheiße.
Aber da gab es doch letztens erst eine Studie zu,
dass Männer tatsächlich diese Schmerzen mitspüren,
weil die ähnliche Hormone ausgeschüttet werden
während der Schwangerschaft der Partnerin.
Oh krass.
Die machen dich eben, also, wie war das?
Gefährliches Halbwissen der Woche.
Oh, das ist eindeutig Halbwissen der Woche.
Mir ist übrigens gerade mein Pad komplett abgeschmiert.
Ich bin jetzt frei von Notizen, was das angeht.
Da müssen wir nochmal bei dir drauf gucken.
Ich habe sie noch offen.
Das Pad ist zwar auch irgendwie halbtot.
Wir haben uns entschlossen, ein Etherpad für unsere Show,
noch für unsere show vorher zu nutzen aber es gibt keine guten ist aber das
thema komplett zu wechseln spontan sorry ja wir sind jetzt hier gerade bei
etherpad beta aber das ist nicht das ist nicht leid gehostet auf ukfn server in
der open knowledge foundation aber es ist man hat sich mittendrin getrennt dann
kam eine anzeige sie wurden diskonnect das habe ich dann irgendwie eine zeit
lang ignoriert und irgendwann habe ich aus versehen neu geladen und das war
natürlich die Daten jetzt komplett weg. Bitte nicht auf
F8, auf 5 drücken.
Na egal, also gefährliches Halbwissen der Woche. Was wolltest du
gerade sagen? Ich meinte
gehört zu haben, das ist natürlich ein super
Intro für gefährliches Halbwissen,
dass... Ich meine, so fängt Donald
Trump jeden dritten Satz an.
Dass bei
Schwangerschaften der Frau,
der Partner,
ähnliche Hormonausschüttungen im Hirn hat
oder generell im Körper,
die dazu führen, dass du
einerseits ruhiger wirst,
was heißt ruhiger, dass du
Empathie aufbaust, dem Partner gegenüber
und andererseits dich vorbereitest,
darauf für das Kind mit da zu sein.
Und das haben Forscher erst vor kurzem herausgefunden,
weil natürlich Studien oft bei Ratten eben
gemacht werden und Rattenväter
kümmern sich zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht um den
Nachwuchs. Das machen nur die Mütter.
Handel oder Rabenväter? Ratten.
Die Nagetiere.
Tatsächlich ist es wohl so,
dass bei Männern der
Testosteronspiegel einbricht,
wenn sie Vater werden.
Hat auch den Seiteneffekt, dass Männer, wenn ihre Frauen schwanger sind, ihre Partnerinnen schwanger sind, gleichzeitig noch an Gewicht zunehmen zusätzlich.
Das ist so diese Scheinschwangerschaft, die Männer dann haben.
Aber diese Gewichtszunahme ist halt auch, das ist genau das, was wurde auch mit erwähnt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das in einem Podcast gehört habe oder gelesen habe irgendwie die letzten Tage.
Gewichtszunahme ist halt ganz klassisch Uhrzeiten.
Wenn du Gewicht zunimmst, dann hast du erstmal ein bisschen mehr ausgesorgt für schlechte Zeiten.
Uhrzeiten?
Ja, genau.
So was wie Uhrzeiten?
Sorry, sorry.
Uhr ohne Haar.
Und hast mehr Energie, um dich um das Kind zu kümmern,
weil du dich weniger um die Nahrungssuche kümmern musst.
Ganz logisch, also verständlich.
Auch ganz klar.
Ja, weiteres gefährliches Halbwesen.
Habe ich vorhin, kurz bevor ich dich
in der Bahn getroffen habe,
bei Science Friday gehört.
Und zwar hat einer Untersuchung gemacht mit Katzenzungen
und dann mit Froschzungen.
Das klingt sehr spannend als Forschungsthema.
Katzenzungen haben ja so kleine Häkchen,
so kleine Widerhäkchen.
Das heißt, wenn du mal von einer Katze
irgendwie so an der Hand gelegt wirst, das kratzt.
und bei Froschzungen
haben sie untersucht, wie die es schaffen
zu kleben und die haben witzigerweise
haben die
jetzt fällt mir der Begriff nicht ein
der
Speichel auf der Zunge eines
Frosches hat die gleichen
Eigenschaften wie Ketchup, das heißt, dass der
seine Viskosität
unter bestimmten Spannungseinwirkungen ändert
das heißt, dass der am viskosesten
ist, am dünnflüssigsten
ist, wenn die
die Zunge ganz weit raus ist und das
Insekt berührt, dann fließt es quasi
da ganz schnell in alle Ritzen.
Und wenn die die Zunge wieder einzieht, dann wird das Zeug
immer fester.
Weshalb
das Insekt dann an der Zunge klebt.
Es war natürlich die Frage, wie kriegt der Frosch
das Insekt von der Zunge wieder ab?
Weil man dann untersucht.
Man sieht ja immer, wenn Frosche schlucken, dann ziehen
die die Augen so rein.
Die Zunge mit runter.
Und dann
die machen die Augen zu und die
Augen
verschwinden dann so kurz in der Kopf, in den Augenhöhlen.
Und es ist tatsächlich so,
das haben sie dann auf
Röntgenbildern untersucht,
dass die mit den Augäpfeln
die
Insekten von der Zunge schieben.
Was ist das denn?
Eine geile anatomische
Begebenheit ist das denn?
Absolut bescheuert.
Das ist großartig.
Oh man, die Natur ist immer
einen Schritt weiter, um sich bescheuerten
Scheiß auszudenken.
Das wäre jetzt,
während wir bei
Methodisch Incorrect, hätte ich das Thema,
hätte ich den Artikel unter dem Thema
Das Auge ist mit.
Könnt ihr mal warten.
Könnt ihr mal warten, ob es demnächst...
Vor allem im Patch stand nur dieser Titel
und ich hätte keine Ahnung, was das geht.
Und jetzt gerade eben hat der das Klick gemacht.
Hast du rausgefunden, wie dieser komische Effekt hieß
mit den Fragestellungen?
Du meinst die
Hinchcliffe's Rule oder auch
Better Riches Law, je nachdem, in welchem Fachbereich
du gerade unterwegs bist.
Better Riches Law betrifft, glaube ich, Journalistik und Hinchcliffs
Rule kommt aus der
Physik oder gerade aus der Particle
aus Particle Physics.
Was ist das auf Deutsch?
Versuch nicht, sagen Sie.
Egal, egal, lass mal sein. Particle Physics
und da gibt es die Hinchcliffs Rule und es geht
eben darum, dass wenn
ein Paper-Titel als
Ja- oder Nein-Frage formuliert ist, dann ist
die Antwort immer Nein.
Und es gibt es eben auch als Better Riches Law of Headlines
in der Journalistik und das ist genau
dieselbe Sache.
Das Witzige ist, dass es
ein Paper gab, was
die Hinchcliffs Rule ein bisschen
angespielt hat.
Das Paper-Titel war einfach nur
Ist Hinchcliffs Rule True?
Was logischerweise einfach zu einem Paradox führt.
Wenn es Ja sein sollte, dann wäre der Paper-Titel
ja falsch. Damit hat es quasi falsch gemacht.
Genau, genau.
Beziehungsweise gibt es laut Wikipedia
genau ein Artikel, wo die
Law Not Applied, also wo
dementsprechend die Antwort tatsächlich ja ist,
aber interessanterweise
geht das Paper sogar um
Betteridge's Law, also um den Journalistik-Effekt.
Also geht es in beiden Papern,
wo dieser Effekt nicht zutrifft,
jeweils um den Effekt letztendlich.
I am so meta, even this acronym.
Genau.
Also das ist eine witzige Sache
und ich müsste jetzt mal ein paar Paper
raussuchen, einfach nur Spaß und Cyber-Thorne.
Ich müsste mal ein paar Paper schreiben, meint ihr ehrlich.
Und dann ganz viele Fragen stellen und die alle mit Ja beantworten.
Ja, mal schauen,
wenn das ein blöder Titel dann ist. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es wirklich daran liegt, dass der Name einfach
scheiße wäre, wenn du deine
eszehende Frage mit Ja beantwortest.
Aber dass es einfach noch kein einziges
Paper gibt, laut Wikipedia, das ist nämlich schon irgendwie.
Hat das irgendwie was damit zu tun, dass das
das dann
zugänglicher ist? Es gibt ja, es gibt doch diese
Fernsehquiz, wo du anrufen
sollst. Dann sollst du entweder A oder B
auswählen. Nicht nur, dass es dir
keine, nicht zumutende
Optionen auszuwählen, sondern es gibt immer nur A
und B. Und es ist grundsätzlich
A richtig und B falsch.
Du meinst jetzt diese Umfragen, wo du 50 Cent
pro Anruf zahlst, pro Minute zahlst.
Und 50 Euro gewinnen kannst. Und das sehr offensichtliche
Rätsel zu lösen. Warum sind diese Rätsel eigentlich immer
so dermaßen offensichtlich? Na, weil die
Geld dafür jeden Anruf kriegen. Ja, aber die sind ja nicht so
jeder Idiot kann gewinnen, sondern so
die sind zu offensichtlich.
Die können ja ein bisschen Puzzling machen, damit Leute
tatsächlich den Wünscher mal anzurufen.
Also es ist meistens sogar die B ist richtig, richtig
sinnlos. Ja, aber das ist ja, warum
ist es so richtig blöd also so so richtig richtig heißt es wenn wasser vom himmel fällt a regen b
titanic so was genau warum sind die so bescheuert ich weiß nicht verstehe es einfach nicht ist eigentlich
sowas in neuen live noch diesen fernsehsender auf dem nur diese bullshit rätsel sendung scheiße war
ich habe keine ahnung ich habe schon seit ewigkeiten kein fernsehen es gibt glaube ich noch irgendwie
solche sportsender wo sowas teilweise schon nachmittag kommt hier diese namen nicht mehr
verdienen, aber... Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es echt nicht. Gefährliches Halbwissen schon wieder.
Ja, so gefährlich ist es nicht.
Mir ist übrigens noch ein Fuck-Up eingefallen. Hast du das von GitLab
gehört? Die haben irgendwas verkackt und
ganz viele Daten gelöscht. Die haben irgendwie
einen Hacker-Angriff
gemerkt oder die haben irgendwie einen DOS-Angriff
gemerkt. Irgendwie hat sich wohl einer versucht, mit irgendwie
über 40.000 verschiedenen IP-Adressen
auf den gleichen Account einzuloggen.
Und daraufhin
hat einer der Admin versucht,
ein bisschen aufzuräumen und hat irgendwie dabei
aus Versehen die Produktionsdatenbank
so, hey, ich lösche mal hier,
oh fuck, das war die Production Database.
Und dann haben sie sich gedacht, ja, ist kein Problem, wir haben ja Backups
und die Backups waren dann allerdings in einem Format, was
mit dem Datenbankformat nicht mehr kompatibel war.
Das heißt, die konnten die nicht ohne weiteres
wieder einspielen. Das ist mir bloß gerade eingefallen,
als du von deinem Problem geredet hast.
Übrigens dazu, und das habe ich dann
ein paar Tage später auf Acker News gesehen,
beziehungsweise ein paar Tage später, das war Stunden später
eigentlich wahrscheinlich,
die haben die Backup-Daten,
die letzten Backup-Daten, die sie hatten,
die dann ein bisschen veraltet waren, so wie es schien,
glaube ich, wieder eingespielt und dabei konntest
du den zwei Typen, die da gearbeitet
haben, live über Twitch zuschauen,
wie sie die Daten wieder eingespielt haben.
Du hast dann auf Twitch
zwei Leute im Kleinen
gesehen, Webcam-Streams und groß
Screenshare von dem einen von denen,
zumindest von einem seiner Desktops und dann
einfach ein Terminal-Fenster in Vollbild,
wo das Datenbank-Backup langsam wieder eingespielt
wurde.
Sehr, sehr spannend. Das machen viele irgendwie so,
Hacking live mit Twitch.
Aber zumindest von GitLab fand ich es cool,
weil es halt so diese Transparenz an der Stelle war.
Du konntest so, also GitLab,
ich weiß nicht, worauf GitLab anzieht,
was deren Masterplan eigentlich ist.
Die wollen ja mit GitHub konkurrieren.
Die sind ja ein Open-Source-Klon von GitHub.
Quasi. Die machen auch ein paar Sachen anders.
Die machen ein paar Sachen anders?
Ja, zum Beispiel diese eingebaute CI, die GitLab hat.
Sie sind komplett, glaube ich, komplett Open-Source.
Ja, genau. Sie sind Open-Source-Klon von GitHub.
Genau.
Aber ekelhafterweise eben auf Rails aufgebaut,
wenn mich alles täuscht, ebenso wie GitHub.
Wie GitHub auch.
Also so, dass du es nicht selbst hosten möchtest.
Fast alle von diesen Seiten auf Rails aufgebaut.
Es gibt noch
Githelicious, ne wie hieß es?
Ach dieses direkte
Git-Hosting, ne, ne.
Ach die sind alle echt keine Ahnung.
Was ich cool finde ist, Gox, beziehungsweise der Nachfolger von Gox,
weil Gox ja von dem einen
Maintainer irgendwie nicht mehr gepflegt wird,
gibt die
dieser minimal in Go
geschriebene GitHub-Klon, der sieht ja eh nicht so GitHub aus,
aber da es halt Go ist, macht das
Deployment halt unglaublich simpel.
Hat das mit T zu tun? Keine Ahnung.
Der Name ist einfach Git-Tee.
Git mit the cup of tea.
Das Logo ist halt auch, und der Slogan...
Keine Ahnung.
Mein Gox hat auch nichts mit Git zu tun.
Es hat ein GitHub-Groß mit Git zu tun,
außer dem Namen.
Also logisch, das ist die Plattform, klar.
Aber was ist ein GitHub für ein Name?
Naja, das ist halt...
Das ist das, was die machen,
und das ist der Hub dafür.
Es gibt ja viele Leute, die lernen Git
und verstehen den Unterschied zwischen Git und GitHub nicht
und denken, GitHub ist Git.
Das heißt, dass deine Marke erfolgreich ist.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist so eine Frage.
GitLab ist noch ein beschissener Name eigentlich.
Was soll denn das?
Als die angefangen haben, sahen die fast genauso aus
von der Oberfläche wie GitHub.
Da finde ich Bitbucket noch cooler vom Namen her.
Echt jetzt?
Nur fast.
Das ist ein Eimer.
Für Bits.
Ich finde immer Bitbucket klingt wie Kickbucket.
Ich frage mich auch,
warum die ihre Issues nicht einfach Bucketlist nennen.
Das ist ja so offensichtlich.
Wieso machen die das nicht? Weil Atlassian
kein Humor hat vermutlich.
Atlassian hat, glaube ich, überhaupt keinen Humor.
Nee, also gut, das war noch ein
absoluter Fuck-up der Woche auf jeden Fall,
diese GitHub-Sache. Da verfällt mir dieser Spruch wieder ein.
Irgendwer hat mal auf HN gepostet,
dass er gerne noch einen Testing-Server
hätte neben seinem Production-Server, um Dinge
auszuprobieren und da hat einer drauf geantwortet
mit, ja, jeder hat einen Testing-Server. Manche haben nur
den Luxus, eben noch einen zu haben, auf dem sie
nicht so viel rumtesten und den Production-Server
nennen. Aber das ist
Production Server, einfach dein Testing-Server.
Hä?
Naja, er meinte einfach nur, wenn du nur einen hast, dann ist das halt
dein Testing-Server, obwohl er Production heißt.
Achso.
Vielleicht habe ich auch, du bist einfach gerade komplett
verstümmelt.
Sorry.
Wir haben noch eine andere Kategorie
uns einfallen lassen, nämlich unsere GitHub-Star
der Woche.
Wer ist denn
GitHub-Star der Woche?
Naja, das Projekt, was wir gestarrt
haben, also favorisiert haben, mit einem Star
versehen haben auf GitHub
in der letzten Woche, da haben wir
beide uns zwei kleine Tools.
Ich weiß nicht, wie klein deine sind.
Ich habe gar nicht so weit geguckt, muss ich
sagen. Ich habe das mal irgendwann gesagt bekommen, dass
die Leute mir auf GitHub gar nicht mehr
folgen, weil ich so viel Star
starre, dass
deren Timeline dann voll gekleinnt wird.
Aber ich mag ja so Dinge zu finden.
Das habe ich mir irgendwie von dir abgeguckt.
Ich mag ja auch Dinge zu starren. Dinge starren ist toll.
Es gibt Leute, die sind
ein bisschen Appreciation, mein Projekt ist toll.
Ich hätte dir vor einiger Zeit mal vorgeschlagen,
hat das schon mal jemand gebaut irgendwie?
Ich hätte gerne einen Bot, der alles,
was ich auf GitHub stare,
vertwittert. Du kannst
deine Timeline sowieso via
RSS-Consume, also
deine Timeline, nicht deine Stars,
du kannst deine Profile-Activity, glaube ich, auch via RSS
abgreifen, dann kannst du den Bot relativ einfach
darüber ziehen, aber ich kenne nichts dergleichen
direkt, das stimmt.
Dann müsste man da was programmieren.
Ja, wieder dieses Stichwort, Hashtag
müsste man mal programmieren.
Das müsste man mal programmieren der Woche.
Ich möchte euch bitte in Zukunft
in den Kommentarspalten dann sehen,
Links zu GitHub-Repos,
wo die Sachen, die wir hier erwähnen,
dann einfach mal gebaut wurden.
Das würde ich dann übrigens auch starren.
Da gibt es einen Subreddit, der heißt
Somebody Build This oder so ähnlich.
Oder Somebody Make This.
Und da habe ich tatsächlich meine Spieleidee abgegriffen.
Die habe ich sogar angefangen, aber nie zu Ende gesetzt.
Aber egal, ist ein Thema für eine andere.
Was ist denn dein erster GitHub-Star
der Woche?
ich weiß nicht du hast das pad bei mir ist es kaputt ach so muss ich mal schauen was habe ich
gestartet der moss händler moss händler was was was hat hat hat mozilla sein sein artwork verändert
die heißen jetzt auf ihrem logo die haben leider den schönen dinosaurier abgeschafft überall große
der Dino ist weg.
Der Dino ist weg
und die haben jetzt aber festgestellt,
dass man aus dem ILL in ihrem Namen
auch Doppelpunkt Slash Slash machen kann.
Das heißt,
die heißen jetzt
mosdoppelpunkt Slash Slash A.
Mod A.
Da kam natürlich sofort einer
auf die Idee,
dieses Protokoll müsste man nochmal registrieren.
Deswegen gibt es den mosdoppelpunkt Slash Slash.
Und daraufhin kannst du
mosdoppelpunkt Slash A Slash
irgendwas als URL eingeben.
Und es sind ein paar URLs hinterlegt.
und das leitet dich alles auf Mozilla-Seiten weiter
ne, das ist halt was da in dieses Plug-in-Heart
reingekodiert ist
ich habe da auf Twitter
gepostet
ich möchte, wenn das Artwork jetzt
dieses komische Doppelpunkt
hat, dieses komische Protokoll
dann müsste ich auch eingeben können Mozilla
slash Rust
kurz darauf kriege ich einem Koppel auf Twitter
einen Link zu einem
Pull-Request, den er an diesen
Händler geschickt hatte mit
you're welcome, da hat er das dann
reingehackt, dass man immer
most.com
slash a
Aber das a ist ja dann irgendwie ein bisschen
Fehlerplatz. Also quasi a ist der
Server, ist die Domain.
Ach so, und dann Punkt oder was?
Slash oder irgendwas.
Und er hat dann Rust als
weiterleitungs-Rust-Wabseite reingehackt.
Ah ja. Aber wo
registriert man eigentlich, wenn ich ein neues Protokoll
ins Leben rufen möchte, das?
Du musst ja wahrscheinlich Geld reinstecken zu irgendeiner offiziellen
Das müssen deine
Applikationen
implementieren.
Wenn nicht, kämen Sie es an einen systemweiten
Händler weiter. Aber wenn Mozilla
beispielsweise das zumindest registrieren möchte,
damit das nicht in Zukunft jemand kaputt macht,
das könnte der Name klappen. Das könnte ich schlauerweise direkt in Firefox einbauen,
so als nicht offizielles
Protokoll. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich der beste
Weg, wenn du schon dein Logo so hast,
dann liegt das so ein bisschen auf der Hand für irgendeinen
Patentroll-ähnlichen Bullshit, dass jemand
versucht, das für irgendeinen
halblichst legitim Scheiß zu nutzen
und dann damit versucht halt
aber nur Beziller zu trollen, massiv.
Die ganzen User-Interface-Geschichten
und interne von
Firefox kannst du alle aufrufen
mit Chrome, Doppelpunkt, Doppelflash.
Chrome, Doppelpunkt.
Doppelflash.
Warum das?
Warum macht Firefox das auch über Chrome?
Firefox macht das schon immer,
weil Chrome der Begriff für
alle Sachen ist, die zum
UI gehören.
Oh Gott.
Das heißt, die Adressleiste
und die Tabs und die Bookmarkbar,
das ist der Chrome der Anwendung.
Ich verstehe den Begriff
aus dem Englischen, klar.
Deswegen habe ich mich gewundert,
als Google plötzlich einen Browser rausgebracht hat,
den sie einfach so genannt haben.
Das fand ich ziemlich bescheuert zu dem Zeichen.
Ich dachte gerade, Mozilla hat das in Firefox eingebaut,
damit die Leute, die von Chrome kommen,
zurechtfinden die Einstellung.
Das siehst du schon bei Mozilla 0.8.
Krass.
Da wäre ich nie drauf gekommen.
Da gibt es dann auch welche direkten
Xul-Ressourcen an.
Du kannst ja auch in Firefox über die About-Seiten
irgendwie da reinkommen, oder?
Du kannst About-About eingeben.
About-About.
Es gibt irgendwie About.
In Kanada.
About-About.
Es gibt About Mozilla.
Und da siehst du immer
from the book of Mozilla so eine Zeile.
Und das ändert sich mit jeder...
Was zum Teufel ist das Book of Mozilla?
Ja, da steht
The Twins of Mammon quarreled
Their worrying plunged
the world into a new darkness
and the beast haught the darkness
Da müsste man eigentlich mal
Oh, da steht übrigens
So it began to move swiftly
and grew more powerful
and went forth and multiplied
and the beast brought fire and light
into the darkness
from the book of Mozilla 15.1
What?
Ich möchte fast behaupten,
das war schon in dem alten Netscape drin
und das aktualisieren die immer bloß, wenn sie einen neuen
Browser rausbringen. Also es kam also
neuer Text, als dann Mozilla 1.0
rauskam.
Firefox hatte einen eigenen Text.
Da gibt es bestimmt im Internet
eine schöne Übersicht drüber.
Krass. Okay, also ich bin mit diesen ganzen Interna
von Firefox, also ich wusste nicht,
dass die so viel Kram da drin haben.
So viel, das ist
Easter Egg schon, oder? Das ist ein Easter Egg.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es bei
About, About ist relativ
neu, da kriegst du eine Übersicht mit diesen ganzen
doch da steht es mit drin genau das fing an mit dem book of mozilla 12 10 dann 337 15 8 20 11 9
und jetzt das aktuellste ist das was ich gerade vorgelesen habe 15 1 und dann gab es noch unter
geschichten von anderen browsers die ähnliche sachen hat noch das war schon in dem zwar schon
Netscape drin. Den Link zu der Wikipedia-Seite
müssen wir mal mit in die Show-Notes dann hauen.
The Book of Mozilla. Da müsst ihr mal bitte
irgendwie so einen alten Coder haben,
der das dann episch so am Lagerfeuer
vorliest. So runterbetet.
Auswendig natürlich.
Oh, schön. Gefällt mir.
Was ist denn dein Getapster
in der Woche? Mein erster ist einfach nur
ein ganz, ganz kleines Tool, was ich entdeckt
habe, was mir gefällt. Einfach nur von
der Idee her, Cargo Plugin. Also Cargo
ist ja das Build-Tool von Rust,
der deiner Lieblingsprogrammiersprache,
einer, mit der ich mich in letzter Zeit immer mehr anfreunde.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, du redest in letzter Zeit viel mehr davon.
Und für Cargo kann man Plugins schreiben,
die man dann einfach mit Cargo Plugin-Namen aufrufen kann.
Das finde ich eine tolle Sache.
Und da hat einer ein kleines Plugin geschrieben,
namens Outdated, Cargo Outdated.
Und das listet dir einfach deine Dependencies auf
und schaut einfach mal,
was ist die aktuelle Version, die du nutzt?
Was ist die nächstkompatible Version davon?
Das, was Cargo Update tatsächlich auch reinziehen würde.
Aber was ist denn so die Latest-Version,
die es tatsächlich auf Quades.io gibt
und gib dir die mit an, damit du auf die updaten kannst.
Das macht das sogar transitiv.
Zeigt dir an, wenn
Abhängigkeiten von dir veraltete Abhängigkeiten
vorhanden sind.
Ja, genau.
Krass.
Einfach nur ein witziges kleines Tool.
Mein anderer Getup Star der Woche ist ein Tool,
was ich unglaublich großartig fand in dem Moment,
wo ich es gesehen habe. Das Ganze heißt
PipEnf. Was?
PipEnf. P-I-P-E-N-V.
Für das Python-Tool
mit PIP, ein Environment Management
Tool, kannst du mal vielleicht sagen dazu.
Das, was mich schon immer angekotzt hat,
wenn ich mit Python arbeite, ist, dass
PIP einfach ein großer stinkender
Haufen Scheiße ist
und das Dependency Management in der Python-Welt
generell. Es ist wieder Treufütterungszeit.
Genau.
Und generell, dass
Python-Abhängigkeiten
mit so einer Requirements-TXT-
Datei liegen, einfach nur, da ist
requirement und dann
ist einfach shop.
TXT-Dateien nimmt man doch, das ist doch was Menschenlesbares.
Genauso wie cmakelists.txt.
Ja, jetzt fang ich damit an.
Aber es ist halt immer kaputt
und irgendwas geht immer kaputt.
Und die Python-Welt hat vor kurzem angefangen
mit pip-Files. Das ein bisschen
aufzubereiten und eine Manifest-Datei für pip
ein bisschen anders aufzubereiten und eine pip-file.log
auch beispielsweise mit anzulegen.
Das sind tolle Dinge.
Nicht, dass nicht schon jemand angefangen hätte,
Python-Pakete mit NPM zu packagen,
weil die Leute ja grundsätzlich alle sind mittlerweile
mit NPM packagend. NPM kann ja auch alles
packagen. Ich habe auch schon absolut nur Pash-Kran
über NPM verschoben. Warum eigentlich
nicht? Ich fühle mich ein bisschen entschuldig dabei,
aber ist okay. Es gibt Firmen, die
schieben Ziprus-Bus-Projekte,
nimmt NPM hin und her.
Jedenfalls ist...
Es gibt ja auch CMake.js.
Oh Gott.
Jedenfalls ist PipEnf
ein wunderbares Tool,
was letztendlich das alles für dich wegabstrahiert,
auch das Nutzen von Virtual Environments,
weil du willst ja eigentlich deine Impendencies auch nicht global installieren,
sondern für dein einiges Projekt immer schön lokal.
Und dann Virtual Vimals ist eine tolle Sache,
aber das Handeln von Virtual Vimals ist auch immer scheiße,
was meistens damit zusammenhängt,
dass Python 2 und Python 3 einfach existieren
und da auch alles scheiße ist.
Ich habe immer Virtual Env benutzt für Sachen,
weil die Anwendungen, die ich in meiner Diplomarbeit geschrieben habe,
aber von Python 2 abhängen
und ich aber auf meinem Art Schluks schon längst Python 3
als Standard Python eininstalliert hatte,
da hatte ich da Probleme mit.
Da gab es jahrelang einen Bug, der nie gefixt wurde,
dass du nämlich, du konntest zwar einen Python 2 Virtual Env aufsetzen,
in dem dann Python, hinter Python, auch Python 2 war,
der hat aber fast alles, also der hat fast alles übersetzt,
was vorher Python 2 hieß, bis auf so ein Package-Config-Fool,
was du immer manuell nachkopieren, um drüber kompilieren musstest.
Und das hat eine absurdeste Fehler bei dir in den Geschmissen,
weil du nämlich dann beim Kompilieren von nativen Plugins
plötzlich wieder Python 3 hattest
und sich das falsch verhalten hat.
Das war großartig.
Das ist, glaube ich, immer mal nicht gefixt.
Dabei gibt es aber pipenv.
Das abstrahiert das alles weg.
Das ist ein wunderbar schönes Tool mit wunderbarem,
schönem Output.
Du sagst einfach nur, was du haben möchtest.
Du machst einfach über pipenv ein neues Env hier.
Der schmeißt eine pip-File hin,
legt deine Dependencies rein,
macht pipenv install und das war's.
Du kannst über pipenv Dinge in dem Environment ausführen.
Du kannst über pipenv Dinge in dein Environment reinpacken.
Du musst nicht mehr manuell mit den Environments
rumspielen und das macht einfach nur
mega Spaß. Und ich habe einmal PIP-Enf installiert
und drei alte Python-Projekte
angefangen, wieder an den rumzudoktern
und es hat einfach nur Spaß gemacht. Plötzlich lief der Scheiß.
Benutzt das irgendwie Virtual Enf?
Es nutzt sowohl
Virtual Enf als auch das, was das
richtige Virtual Enf 3 ist.
PIP-Enf ist in Python
geschrieben.
Ja.
Du installierst es auch über PIP.
So. Was ist denn, wenn ich
auf dem System bin, wo es dieses Python
nicht gibt. Dann gibst du dir wieder einen Kopfschuss
und dann schmeißt Python weg.
Python ist so eine tolle Sprache.
Ich finde es schön, dass es das gibt.
Ich hätte gerne schon vor zwei Jahren
davon gewusst.
Eines der Kavien ist auch, Windows is not currently supported,
aber wer macht schon Python-Dinge auf Windows?
Ja, nee.
Es ist so wie
DIA-Enf. Funktioniert DIA-Enf
eigentlich auf dem Mac?
Ich meine schon. Ich habe es nur, ich glaube,
mal kurz probiert,
Spaß zu haben,
aber ich bin nie so wirklich komplett reingekommen.
Ich weiß bloß, dass dieses Tool existiert
und wunderbar saubere, also letztendlich
alles managt für, unabhängig
von deinem Projekt, von deiner Programmiersprache, von deinem
Frameworks, Tools, was auch immer und
eigentlich, wenn du es einmal richtig einstellst,
immer funktioniert und plötzlich läuft alles.
Das ist alles, was über dir ein Fall ist.
Ja, ich muss mir mal sowas für Windows
raussuchen.
Rennst da gegen Wände.
Naja, ich möchte jetzt nicht drauf eingehen.
Okay. Aber hey, ich habe
mein Pad wieder aufgekriegt. Das heißt,
ich weiß jetzt, was jetzt als nächstes
wenn ich hier mal
gerade
auf Biere eingeladen.
Sehr schön.
Oh, ich habe auch noch was.
Also Cargo outdated, es gibt auch noch, wie man kann
ja gut, okay,
wir müssen jetzt mit dem Rust-Thema
wieder aufhören, aber wenn man auf Craigs.io nach Cargo
sucht, findet man tonnenweise wunderschöne
Cargo-Plug-Ins,
die man benutzen kann. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch
Cargo Tree,
was einem den transitiven Abhängigkeitsbaum seiner Anwendung zeigt.
Und dann sieht man auch mal, ob bestimmte Sachen mehrfach in unterschiedlichen Versionen in seinem Code auftauchen.
Cool.
Also wie das generell funktioniert, muss man glaube ich auch mal.
Das würde mich interessieren.
Naja, der fragt die API ab.
Nee, aber ich meine generell, wie ein Projekt damit klarkommt,
wie die Dependencies funktionieren.
und wenn die in unterschiedlichen Versionen vorliegen.
Ja, es gibt unterschiedliche Ansätze.
Es gibt den Ansatz von NPR.
Lass das mal bitte in einem extra Thema irgendwann mal.
Der sagt einfach,
oh, du verwendest Abhängigkeit A
und Abhängigkeit B
und Abhängigkeit B verwendet auch Abhängigkeit A.
Dann hast du Abhängigkeit A jetzt einfach zweimal.
Ja, das ist für ein Skript ja scheißegal,
weil du kompilierst den Kack ja nicht
und du kannst ja auch tatsächlich
dieselben SOS in unterschiedlichen Versionen
unterschiedliche APIs auch in deinem Projekt
drin haben und die werden auch einfach genutzt.
Das Witzige bei JavaScript ist allerdings, wenn du ein
Modul requirest
und jemand anders das gleiche
Modul requiret, dann kriegt ihr
dieselbe Instanz davon. Das heißt,
das verhält sich quasi wie ein Singleton.
Aha. Abgefahren.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was das für Auswirkungen hat,
wenn du unterschiedliche Versionen davon drin hast.
Auf jeden Fall geht das ja auch. Das ist ja das Witzige.
Das ist so einfach, vor allem irgendwie geht
in der JavaScript-Welt.
Und dann gibt es einen Ersatz für NPM,
der immer noch NPM benutzt, aber ein anderes
in den anderen Kommandozeilen-Client
verwendet, der heißt Yarn.
Und der hat einen Flat-Modus.
Und der versucht, deine Abhängigkeiten
glatt zu ziehen. Aber die nutzen doch nicht NPM als Backend.
Doch. Die nutzen doch Facebook-gehostetes
NPM als Backend.
Du kannst es, glaube ich, auf das gleiche
Teil schmeißen. Achso, okay.
Also du kannst die Registries auch umschalten.
Okay. Aber was ist denn?
Was ist denn der Flat?
Flat-Modus heißt, du hast nicht Abhängigkeit A
und Abhängigkeit B und B hat Abhängigkeit,
unten drunter hängt nochmal A als Abhängigkeit
zweites Mal dran und dann legt das alles flach nebeneinander in einen Ordner.
Und dann müssen gefälligst
die Versionen miteinander kompatibel sein.
Ja und wenn nicht, was kannst du versitten dann?
Dann machst du nicht an Install und
die gibt nicht Fehler.
Du solltest hoffen, dass die Leute Semantic Versioning
sauber einhalten. Ja, einerseits das
und andererseits natürlich auch updaten.
Wenn die Dependencies nicht updaten oder
die Dependencies nicht updaten, die ihre Dependencies nicht updaten,
müsste man mal rum experimentieren.
Dann geht es doch mal kaputt.
bewegen wir uns gerade schon wieder in gefährliches
Halbwissen. Freitag ist
JavaScript User Group Treffen.
Ich bin kein JavaScript-Mensch.
Egal.
Was mir
aufgefallen ist, ich habe nur mal kurz mit Jahren rumgespielt,
die haben so einen Garbage Collect
Befehl, wo die versuchen, es gibt ja
Node Packages, die irgendwie
ganze Encyclopedien mit ausliefern,
nur um ihren Namen
mit einer Unterschrift versehen zu können.
Gab es nicht Note-Packages, die Bilder von
Guy Fieri mitpackagen?
Also Note-Packages
liefern eine ganze Menge Scheiß mit aus manchmal
und dann hat man plötzlich einen Gigabyte in seinen
Dependencies umliegen, die man nicht braucht. Also irgendein Paket
hat dann einen seltsamen Namen und die haben einfach bloß als
Dependency
noch, glaube ich, die Encyclopedia Britannica
oder auch so. Das gab es auch
als NPM-Paket. Haben sie mit reingesogen, damit
sie dir einblenden könnten, was ihr Name bedeutet.
Großartig.
Krass.
Das war der Blogpost, I looked in my
Node-Modules-Folder and looked what I found.
War wahrscheinlich, glaube ich, derselbe Blogpost mit dem Guy Fieri-Folder.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist mir eingefallen, als ich gesehen habe,
dass Jan so einen Garbage-Collection-
Befehl hatte, der hat dann einfach
alles, der hat geguckt, was brauche ich, was binde ich ein,
guck mal kurz drüber, und hat dann versucht,
so Dokumentationen und Scheiß wegzuschmeißen,
die ich nicht brauche. Es gibt auch eine
.mpm-ignore-Datei, die
du wirklich gut führen solltest, damit
nicht einfach dein gesamtes Source-Verzeichnis
Weil sich NPM nicht anguckt,
was JavaScript ist und was nicht,
sondern es schmeißt einfach alles, was
in deinem Root-Verzeichnis ist, mit rein.
Der war da drüber
und schmeißt das Zeugs weg und das hat
spontan eine Anwendung, die ich gerade gebaut habe, kaputt gemacht.
Was? Weil es halt Essens
weggeschmissen hat, die du gebraucht hast. Ach so.
Großartig. Na gut, aber wenn die halt
wichtig sind, dann sollen die halt nicht nur werden.
Klar. Wo wir gerade
bei Rust waren, ach scheiße.
Ich habe am Wochenende versucht,
eine Kommandoteilenanwendung, die ich habe,
mal zu lokalisieren.
Als es mir ein bisschen auf den Keks ging,
dass ich irgendwie das Kommando-Teil-Interface
auf Englisch habe und sowieso
die Fehlermeldung ist ja komplett auf Englisch, weil man macht nicht immer alles auf Englisch.
Auf der anderen Seite sind die Benutzer
komplett nur Deutsch und das
Ding generiert halt so einen Kalender
und den hätte ich gerne auf Deutsch gehabt.
Das fand ich irgendwie blöd, dass das Ding halb Deutsch, halb Englisch ist.
Also habe ich angefangen, na gut, okay, dann lokalisiere
ich den Scheiß jetzt und habe ein ziemlich
cooles Crate gefunden. Das heißt
Crowbook Intel.
Also es gibt eigentlich ein Tool, das heißt Crowbook,
das übersetzt, glaube ich, unterschiedliche E-Book-Formate hintereinander.
Auch ziemlich krass.
Und die Frauen, die das gebaut hat, hatten...
Also ich fand, sollte ich das erwähnen?
Ist das sexistisch, dass ich das hervorhebe? Keine Ahnung.
Ich finde es cool, dass das eine Frau ist.
Und das ist ein ziemlich abgefahrenes Projekt.
Die hatten dafür ein Internationalization-Crate gebaut.
Das verhält sich so ein bisschen wie Get-Text.
Das gibt es auch.
Das kennen Leute aus der C-Welt.
Das geht über deinen Code drüber,
denn überall, wo du den Text rausprintest,
schreibst du ein Makro davor,
in C macht es das einfach so, glaube ich.
Dann schreibst du eine Datei
mit all deinen Strings.
Das ist eine Default.
Das ist so quasi die Basisvariante.
Die kopierst du, nennst die Deutsch,
dann schreibst du überall zu jedem String,
den du gefunden hast, die deutschen Varianten drunter
und dann kompilierst du es zusammen.
Das Ding schafft es trotzdem,
Formal-Strings immer noch zur Compile-Zeit zu evaluieren.
und bindet dann
live zur Laufzeit
jeweils die deutsche oder englische
Fassungsliste ein, je nachdem was du für eine Sprache
setzt. Und die setzt du wie?
Und die setzt du, indem du eine globale
Variable setzt. Achso, eine
environment-variable? Ja,
eine globale Variable in der Anwendung, aber
die kannst du auch erst eine endvariable ziehen.
Also das ist nicht automatisch das System.
Aber das Coole ist einfach, dass du
beim Bauen diese Vorlagendatei
neu erzeugst. Wenn du irgendwo einen neuen String hinzufügst,
dann musst du den einfach zu deiner erzeugten,
abgewandelten Deutsch-Datei wieder hinzufügen.
Und dann kopierst du das und bindest andere Sprachen ein.
Das funktioniert ziemlich cool.
Das finde ich cool.
Ich kenne Localization eigentlich nur aus der,
also da, wo ich es hauptsächlich nutze, in der iOS-Welt.
Da legst du halt eine sogenannte Strings-Datei mit in deinem Projekt,
wo deine ganzen Strings halt eben definiert sind.
Die haben einen Identifier und einen Wert.
Diese Datei existiert für jede Sprache.
iOS wählt dann aufgrund
von deinem Systemlokal
halt das Korrekte aus, du musst halt
angeben, was ist deine Default-Localization,
meistens Englisch, und das kriegen ja alle die,
für die keine Übersetzung vorliegt, und alle anderen kriegen,
wenn eine vorliegt, ihre eigene.
Und du greifst dann halt über Apple APIs,
über so ein NS-Localized-String,
heißt das, auf diese Strings zu, und nicht
mehr über den Label
befüllst mit einem Wert, dann sagst du, es ist nicht mehr
Label, es ist der String, sondern Label, es ist ein NS-Localized-String,
und dann passiert da Magic im Hintergrund,
das eigen rauszieht ziemlich genau fühlt sich das auch an es klingt nicht cool gerade das ist
alles auf komponente kommt halt an dem läuft und ich habe da so ein bisschen befürchtung dass das
das ding dass du die aus statischen strings plötzlich dynamische strings macht aber es hat
sich ziemlich cool angeführt das war mein zweiter github star der woche läuft dass das können bei
behalten als topic schauen wir so über die wochen mit podcast ja wir haben ja noch einen guten
Backlog an GitHub Stars zu verfügen.
Ja, sehr, sehr viel.
Aber ich will Dinge, die ich diese Woche
tatsächlich gestartet habe, anbringen und nicht
alten Kram.
So, vielen Dank, dass ihr mir das jetzt durchgehalten habt.
Ja, wir haben knapp über
eine Stunde diesmal aufgenommen. Das war ein Podcast
für Leute, die gerne Podcasts machen, aber keine Ahnung
haben, wie man Podcasts macht.
Ich hätte mir eigentlich vorgenommen, dass ich mal ein Headset
von Arbeit mitbringe.
Also falls irgendwer uns Feedback
geben möchte, wir wären sehr interessiert dran, was Audioqualität
angeht.
Sag nicht, wie wir aufnehmen.
Wenn irgendjemand uns Headsets schicken möchte.
Also wie wir aufnehmen ist
nicht würdig, aber
ich finde es geht,
wenn ich es mir anhöre, aber ich kann es schlecht beurteilen.
Also im Gegensatz zu allen anderen Podcasts,
die ich höre, befindet sich unsere von der Qualität
ja im guten Mittelfeld, würde ich behaupten.
Also wir haben jetzt hier spontan, nachdem es endlich mal wieder Zeit
wurde, haben wir wieder eine Folge aufgenommen. Die nächste wird hoffentlich
ein bisschen geplant. Das war Folge 1.
Akronymisierbar.
Wünsche euch einen schönen Abend.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Oder einen guten Morgen.
einen guten Start in den Tag. Hoffentlich hat das Frühstück
geschmeckt.
Oder ein guter Mittagessen.
Bleibt sexy. Bis dann. Bis dann.